で 論理は自業自得ということなんですね
で 祈りではなくて 自業自得という法則
これが明らかな事実ですよ
で あの深いことをわからないで言っても
今現在 今 自分の人生も自業自得でしょうね
自分でやることによって結果得ている
仕事を真面目にすれば給料をもらうし
いい加減にすれば給料と同時に非難もいただくし
だからもういつでも毎日
日々 毎秒毎秒 我々は自業自業自得という法則で生きているんですよ
それが確かな事実ですから
生命全体的になんで自業自得は悪いんですか？これっておかしいんですよ
どんな生命を見ても どんな瞬間で観察しても
自業自得なんです ゴキブリを見ても
ミミズを観察したっても
鳥たちを観察したっても
いつでも自業自得 自分で行ったことは自分で得るという法則で生きているんですよ
ですから で そういうわけで
生命全体的に自業自得法則であるというのは
ものすごい明確な理論なんです
例えば人が肺炎になった
それは自業自得ではないんだよと言えませんよ
ウイルスに感染したんだぞとかね
やっぱりどんなことを見ても
やっぱり自業自得という法則に当てはめます
そういうことだから 確実な法則です
ちょっと自分を観察すれば
これは自業自得であると
私はずっと立っていて
すごく疲れているんです
自業自得なんですよ 立っていたのは私の責任で立っているんだから
あなた方のせいで疲れますと言えないでしょうに
皆様頼んでないんだから
ずっと立って喋りなさいよと
だからまあ自業自得なんです
だからどんなものでも
ですから 自分が生きている間
精一杯善行為をすることが
自分の今世の幸福 死後の幸福を確保する唯一な保証なんです
だからアメリカンダイレクトとかね
あんなの買ったっても
まあもうあの 何でしたっけ？いろいろ保証会社がありますからね
で あの 60歳でも 70歳でも簡単に入れますよとかね
で もう確実にお金くれると思いますかね
ものすごい危ないんですよ
そういう会社は人のお金取っているんだから
何かあったらお金払わなくちゃいけないし
大体お金払ってくれないっていうのは普通ですけど
そうすると日本の法律で裁かれるし
会社倒産したら自分払ったお金全部パーでしょうに
だからあまりあの保険とっても全然保証はないんです
しかし 自業自得は確実なんです
自分がしっかり勉強すると頭が良くなるのは決まっているし
自分がすごく真面目に勉強の仕事のことをよく学んで
身について ちゃんと間違いなく失敗なく仕事をするならば
自分がすごく楽に仕事できるということは当たり前で
人に怒鳴られても怒鳴り返さない場合は
まあ全然問題起こらないということは当たり前で
誰にしたっても悪口ものすごく散らかしているならば
機関銃のようにみんなに非難を受けるのは当たり前のことで
そんな複雑なことじゃないんです
それは科学的に見ても
どんな行為も結果その場で出すんです
で 私はこの 何といいますか
これなんとかという機械ですけど
で これを緩めたら落ちるんです
そんなに難しいでしょうかと
それぐらい確実なんですよ
この自業自得論は だから日本で儀式的に自業自得っていうのは悪いことに使うんだと思っているのは
まあそれは単なる感情で
哲学的な思考じゃないんです
漢字見ると全然悪いこと書いてないんです
自分の行為に自分行為は自分が得るというぐらいの話ですよ
これは正見の大事条件なんです
自業自得を信じる人が正見なんです
そういうわけで 我々いっぱいもうなんていうか
異論成り立ちません 生きている間では
できるだけたくさん もうもう機会があったら良いことをする
機会作ってでも良いことをする
強引にでも良いことをするという
一生もう一生もう善行をする人生にした方が
もう幸福になることは明らかなことになるんです
来世あるかないかとか考えなくてもいいんです
そんな脳細胞ではそんなこと考えられませんだからね
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
自業自得法則だから もう幸福になるに決まってる
だから決して来世のこともう考える必要も心配する必要もなくなっちゃうんです
大丈夫だと 今も私は善行にして生きているし
うまくいっているし 全然不幸にならないし
もう悩んでる 後悔することっていうのは全然ないんだよと
だから死後あった あったならばあったで
ないならばなかったでいい
どっちでもいいんだよと
いうふうに すごく自信満々で生きていられます
親の善行為は親の幸福になるが
子の幸福になりません
自業自得法則から見ると
他人の行為 私の弟が真面目に勉強すると
私は試験合格するということはないでしょうに
弟が司法試験合格したんだから
兄貴たる私も弁護士だよと
とよく思ってること そんなのは
ありえませんよ だから親が良いことをするならば
それは親の幸福になる
子が善いことをするならば
それは子の幸福になる
親の因縁が子供に来るんだそうというのは
これって邪見もまあ恐ろしいんですよ
ご先祖様の不幸がもう次の世代に来るそうとかね
あまりにも原始的な邪見なんです
現代的でもないし 理性的でもないんです
それだったら家で誰か頭のいい人が勉強すればいいんです
みんな合格するんです
だって家族でしょう 家の人に誰かが弁護士になったら
家族中みんな弁護士になっちゃえばいいんです
勉強好きな人にあんたは医者になりなさいと
それから我々が一人一人が病院を作って営業やりますよと
だから いかに邪見も変なことを人間考えるのかという
人の行為は自分には何の関係もないんです
それはわが子であろうと
相手であろうか 伴侶であろうが
全然関係ないんです あくまでも確実に自業自得という法則です
それで仏教では回向するという式でやりますね
テーラワーダ 我々の組織でももう回向するということは
もういつでも必ずやります
でないとどう ことだ 回向する人は自分で善行為をしているんです
だから回向する自分が良いことをしているんですよ
これは独り占めにしませんと
というなおさら善行為しているだけ
無執着の無欲の心がさらに強化するんです
例えば善行為をすることも
無執着無欲の心を育てることですよ
その上 回向までしちゃうと
せっかく自分が苦労して功徳を得たのに
それをすべての生命に
はい どうぞもらってくださいというんだから
なおさら自分の心が無執着状態に
無欲状態になるんです
だから回向に効き目がないとは言えません
したがって 回向を勧誘するものです
自分が回向するから他人が幸福になる
他人が善行為しなくても良いとすると
それは調子に乗りすぎです
邪見に陥るんです  お父さん何しなくてもどうぞ好き勝手に酒飲んで悪いことをして遊びをしていてください
私は瞑想して回向しますから
と これが邪見ですよ 回向の効き目って何なのかと
回向は無効な無駄な行為ではありません
共に喜ぶ 賛同するという働きがあります
世の中で共に喜ぶ 賛同するという働きがありますよ
誰かがね  スポーツの世界で何かメダルでも取ったらみんな喜んでしまうというね
他人の善行為を喜ぶこと
賛同することは自分の善行為です
ですから 人が例えば真面目に瞑想している
それを見て なんていい人でしょうか
とても真面目に修行しているんだと
立派な人ではないか とても良かった
良かったと 自分もそれは共に喜ぶ
その行為に賛同する そうすると自分も善行為したことになるんです
それって回向なんです
相手が別な人が良いことをして
私はそれに賛同することで
私もこの功徳をもらうという
他人の回向を素直に喜んで賛同して受けるならば
自分の善行為になるんです
ですから 回向に効き目があるんだけど
その場合も自業自得の法則なんです
回向を受ける人は共に喜ぶ
賛同するという 自分が受信機を合わせておかないとダメなんです
ですから 親が善行為することは
子が喜んで協力したり賛同したりするならば
子も幸福になる 良いことをするのはお母さんだけですけど
子供は全然もうすごい楽しがっている
あ よかったと よかったとか
うちのお母さんはね こういうこともしているんだ
こういうこともしているんだとかね
友達に言いふらしたりして喜んでいると
本人が賛同しているんですよ
その場合は お母さんが良いことをするたびに
子供にもこの幸福が入ってくるんです
この善行為を心から喜ぶ親にも
この子供のね 子供の善行為を心から喜ぶ親にも
その善行為の結果を得ることができる
それで子供が修行したり
良いことをしたり 真面目に生きたりすると
親が喜んで うちの子はね
本当にいい子でとかね
喜んだりする場合は 自分にもその功徳が伝わってくる
だからそこで回向ということは儀式ではなくて
実際起こるものなんです
だから儀式に儀式を馬鹿にしたんだけど
回向することも儀式でしょうと
表面的に見れば明らかに儀式なんです
しかし 裏にしっかりした働きがあるのです
しかし 現実は違いますね
互いに賛同するのではなく
猛反対するんですね 世の中では
だからもう叱ったものじゃないんです
誰かが宗教に興味持っちゃうと
もう猛反対する 良いことをしようと思っちゃうと
そんなことをやめて 何か儲かることを考えればどうでしょうかとかね
言ったりする だと思った
それではまあ終わりですけど
まあ善行為ってのは本当に難しいでしょうかと
いかに心を清らかに保つのかということは
善行為の基本です 善行為っていうのはそんなに難しいことじゃなくて
自分の心を清らかに保つ
汚れないように気をつけるぐらいですよ
だから家は清らかにする
清潔に保つことに必死でしょうに
そのように自分の心も綺麗に保つようにすることが善行為なんです
優しい言葉を使い 人を助ける
ボランティアをするなどで
自分の心をある時間でも綺麗に保つことができます
ですから これは二次的に優しい言葉をかけることや
人を助けてあげることや
いろんなことをすると
またその間では心は綺麗になるんです
しかし 行為が先行したと思っちゃうと
ちょっとやりづらくなるんです
どこまでボランティアやるのかとかね
月一回ぐらいはできますけどと
それは当然そうでしょうね
毎日ボランティアやろうと思っちゃう
自分が生きていられなくなっちゃうし
だからあんまりこの具体的な行為に重点を置いちゃうとやりづらくなるんです
まあなんかカルト宗教になっちゃうんです
何があってもやるんだぞとかね
それではなくて 心を清らかに保つ
行った善行為を思い出して喜ぶことでも
さらに心が清らかになる
例えば月一回ボランティアやってもしかできない
それだったら月一回はやる
それから それはよく思い出したりで
月一回やりますからね
この日でまたやりますから
思い出すたびに心は綺麗になるんです
瞑想実践は直接心を清らかにするんですね
だから瞑想実践はなんで最高の善行やというと
直接心そのものを清浄にする行為なんです
だから善行為の中で一番トップになるんです
そんなところだと思います
誰も誰も当てにならない
この肉体さえも自分の希望通りにならない
病気になったり老いたりして自分を裏切る体
したがって 他人は自分のことを真面目に心配する気すると期待しない方が良いです
自分の体さえも当てにならないんだから
他人は自分のことを心配してくれるとすごい勘違いなんです
人に文句まで言うでしょうね
心配してくれないよとか
面倒見てくれないとかね
あまりにも勘違いというか邪見というか
あなたの体はあなたのことを心配してくれるのかというと
それでもないでしょうに
他人様は自分のこと 自分のことで精一杯ですよ
子供は子供のこと精一杯ですからね
親のことまでもう手が回らないんです
生きている間は一切の幸福を確保できる絶好のチャンスなのです
ですから 我々には生きている時間
生きている間 これが絶好のチャンスなんですよ
あの なんていいますか
一切の幸福を確保するために
これは自分でやらなくちゃいけないんです
それは生きている間でやらなくちゃいけないんです
ということで 今日の話は終わるんです
はい まあちょっと余分に言いますけど
このまあ儀式 儀礼などなどは仏教にもあります
何でも断言的にダメダメと言うんじゃなくて
この まあ適当なところで
ほどほどに 中立的に中道的に物事を見るべきなんですよ
まあですから 派手な服をやめて
落ち着いた惨めな服を着ていると
自分が気持ちが落ち着くならば
まあ別にそれでいいんですけど
だからといってそれは儀式にする必要はないんです
あんまりも厳しくお化粧すると
自分がなんかすごいわがままになったりして
なんか自分をなんか過剰評価したりして心が汚れるならば
まあお化粧を控えめにすると
だからといってお化粧をしてはいけません
これは仏教だからとね
これはちょっとおかしいんですね
いくらお化粧しても 自分の心は全くもう高慢にもならないし
汚れることもないし それだったら別に思い存分お化粧したってもね
どうったことはないんです
だから宗教的な儀式でも
自分の心は喜べる程度で考えて
いつでも中道的に行うべきものなんです
だから 死者儀礼やるかやらないかというと
まあ人間 文明人はみんなやりますから
まあ適当な範囲でやる
だからといって自分の見栄を張って
俺がすごい盛大に葬式やったぞと世間に見せびらかすためにやるならば
これは死者にとって死者の弔いにはならないんですよ
ただ自分の宣伝になるだけでしょうに
そういうことで 一人一人があの
どこまでやるのかと 占いに頼るんじゃなくて
どんな程度で占ってもらうのかどうかね
それは一人一人で考えればいいし
しかし 論理的には祈りには効き目がありません
祈っちゃうと逆効果になる
しかし 仏教の誓願というのは心理的に効き目があります
そんなところなんですね
儀式儀礼に対して言いたい
余分に言いたいところは
なかなか人間なら儀式という風になってますから
これがきれいさっぱり取り消すということはできないんです
取り消しちゃうと なんか人間としてなんか硬くて滑らかがなくなっちゃうんですね
ちょっとふざけていろいろ祭りやったり踊ったりすると
ちょっと人間として滑らかなんですよ
それから人間関係も出来上がりますし
楽しいしね  そういうポイントは決して悪いポイントではありません
そういうことで 結論なし
講演は終わります はい
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます